bonjour Marc fen bonjour bonjour vous
étiez hier en déplacement avec Emmanuel
Macron dans le Pas de Calais depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant les habitants
font face à à des intempéries
dévastatrices l'eau monte encore dans
quel état sont les agriculteurs que vous
avez rencontré oh dans un état dans
l'état de personnes qui ont vu l'eau
monter on commencé à voir l' monter tout
début novembre le 3 ou le 4 et qui
depuis n'ont pas vu l'eau descendre et
et voi les précipitations continue à
s'accumuler j'ai vécu ça dans ma commune
quand j'étais maire en 2016 il y a un
sentiment d'impuissance qui est terrible
dans ces cas-là en se disant que le jour
est sans fin et que ça n'arrêtera jamais
deuxième élément j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait beaucoup de solidarité entre les
habitants entre les agriculteurs entre
les agriculteurs et les habitants c'est
ce qu'on a constaté avec le président de
la République ce qui n'est pas une
surprise on connaît les Français dans
ces momentslà d'extrême solidarité puis
une grande lassitude morale une fatigue
d'abord une fatigue physique parce que
vous passez nuit et jour quand vous avez
des animaux et puis puis on dort pas en
fait dans ces dans ces momentsl donc une
grande fatigue physique qui confine
maintenant à la fatigue psychologique
avec en plus l'espoir que ça redescende
quand même parce que ça finira bien par
redescendre descendre mais le sentiment
que quand ça va quand l'eau va va
rentrer dans son lit si vous me
permettez cette expression retourner à
la mer euh le une partie du dur continue
parce que il faut nettoyer les maisons
il faut nettoyer les équipements des des
agriculteurs il faut vérifier si les
machines marchent on a des frigos qui
sont sont hors service et cetera donc la
remise en route elle-même est longue
pour l'avoir connu moi-même je le répète
et je vois très bien à quel point ça
peut frapper les esprits vous avez tenté
de faire un état des lieux vous savez
combien d'exploitations par exemple ont
été touché alors on on vous on on on a
des des dé nombrements euh aujourd'hui
qui sont de l'ORS d'une centaine mais ça
dépend de quel degré c'est celles qui
sont dans les avec les battés inondés
mais il y a aussi des terres qui sont
inondées des cultures qui sont inondées
on peut pas y accéder hein quand vous
avez 1,50 d'eau vous savez pas ce qu'il
y a dessous ce qui reste dessous et dans
quel ét c'est qu'on connaît pas l'état
des cultures aujourd'hui on peut pas le
savoir quand vous avez un m d'eau on
peut imaginer ce que ça va donner euh il
faut juste laisser le temps de la décru
et à partir de la décru on aura une
vision plus complète de l'étendue des
dégâts de quel type de culture il s'agit
B il y a des grandes cultures euh des
cultures qui ont été semées euh qui ont
pu être semées eu du cols par exemple il
y a des cultures qui étaient encore en
place je pense à de la betterrave qui ne
pourra pas être récolté ou est-ce que la
betterve c'est important he parce que
c'est une région euh très une grand
région betteravière vous avez raison euh
avec des cultures qui manifestement à à
l'heure où je vous parle il faut
toujours être prudent parce que la météo
joue des parfois des tours et parfois
des tours positifs euh mais aujourd'hui
on voit bien que c'est des betteraves
qui seront pas récoltées c'est plusieurs
milliers d'hectares sans doute de
betteraves qui pourront pas être récolté
puisqu'on était au début au milieu de la
saison de récolte de la betterave puis
vous avez des cultures maréchères alors
là on était dans le moment intermédiaire
mais vous avez quand même des chou pour
rentrer dans le détail ouis qui était au
moment où on commençait à les récolter
et qui sont perdus pour un tiers ou les
de tiers d'entre eux donc voilà donc ça
va toucher à court terme les les C les
les récolte qui devait avoir lieu dans
les prochaines semaines les prochains
mois comment ça se passe aussi pour les
élevages on a entendu des témoignages
d'éleveurs qui disait j'ai dû essayer de
sauver mes mes mes bêtes de de la noyade
alors le décomte on le connait mieux il
y a eu des opérations absolument
incroyables de sauvetage d'élevage avec
des éleveurs avec des pompiers avec la
enfin bref donc des animaux qui étaient
en train de se noyer qu'on a pu sauver
il y a une sans doute 200 beauvins qui
ont été perdus et qui ont été noyés par
la montée des eau trop brutales et qui a
pas permis de les évacuer donc ça c'est
documenté alors après vous avez des pour
dire des choses très concrètes vous avez
des éleveurs qui ont des robots de
traite ou des matériels de traite qui é
inopérant chez eux parce qu'il est
inondé donc on déplace tous les jours
les beauvins pour aller les faire traire
dans d'autres dans d'autres structures
donc c'est des c'est beaucoup de de
logistique de logistiqueil faut mettre
en place après on a un deuxième sujet
d'inquiétude c'est euh un animal qui
reste c'est comme vous et moi hein quand
un animal qui reste 24 48 72 he avec de
l'eau jusqu'au coup pas impossible qu'on
ait des maladies qui apparaissent donc
après mais ça c'est aussi des des des
surcouts et des difficultés qu'on verra
et qu'on découvrira au au gré ça veut
dire que les dégâts en fait euh qu'on va
qu'on va découvrir avec la décru il y a
ce qu'on va voir tout de suite voà ce
qu'on va voir à moyen terme et sur le
long terme des coups donc c'est tout ça
qu'il faut essayer de mesurer avec avec
les agriculteurs et leurs organisations
vous étiez à côté d'Emmanuel Macron hier
quand il a annoncé la création d'un fond
de soutien de 50 millions d'euros pour
le pas de calis quelle part pour les
agriculteurs alors ça c'est pour c'est
un fond de soutien pour les
collectivités locales en supplément de
ce que seront les autres dispositions
assurancielles pour ce qui est du monde
agricole pour les alors je cumule
Bretagne Normandie haute-fance c'est un
fond de la tempte aussi oui parce que
malheureusement on a aussi ces épisodes
et je serai en Bretagne jeudi et
vendredi là c'est un fond de 80 millions
d'euros qui permettra de couvrir à la
fois les pertes de récoltes mais aussi
les pertes d'investissement qui serait
pas couvertes par les les les sujets
d'assurance on a fait un fond qui permet
d'éviter pardon l'expression des trous
dans la raquettete par qu'on voit bien
qu'il y a toujours des sujets certains
perdent plutôt des investissements et du
matériel mais il y a il y a un taux
d'usure donc ils sont mal couverts par
les assurances et comment on peut les
les accompagner c'est avec des
investissements puis on est beaucoup en
dialogue avec les régions j'aourais
quand même souligné l'engagement des
régions hier avec Xavier Bertrand le xîn
Gérard ou Hervé Morin pour travailler à
regarder comment dans leur propres
compétences en terme d'investissement
ils peuvent travailler sur les pas les
indemnisations mais le le fait de
relancer la machine économique dans dans
le pas decaléis l'état de catastrophe
naturelle a été reconnu hein dans 244
communes c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
président de la République prière série
commune hier voilà vous rendez demain et
après-demain dans le finisterè la
Bretagne on le disait suite au dégâts
cusés par la tempête carane Emmanuel
Macron avait aussi promis l'état de
catastrophe naturelle partout où on
pourra le faire c'est ce qu'avait dit le
président le but étant là aussi que les
agriculteurs soi vite indemnisé mais là
mais finalement rien pas de catastrophe
naturelle en
bretagnep Y a d'autres instruction
l'état de catastrophe naturelle il est
il peut-être activé dans très dans très
peu de cas mais dans un certain nombre
de cas quand il y a de la tempête mais
plutôt pas en métropole plutôt dans les
outresmers manifestement les CR qu'on
fait dans le pas calé oui mais c'est des
inondations donc ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas un phénomène tempéueux donc et donc
là les Bretons il pas droit donc donc on
a d'autres dispositifs le système des
calamités agricoles il fonctionne sans
les catastrophes naturelles donc il
s'activera de même nature le système des
catastrophes naturell il permet
principalement de regarder dans quel
caisse c'est pris est-ce que c'est les
assureurs ou la caisse mutualisée des
assureurs ça n'empêchera pas qu'en
Bretagne aussi les les les risques ou
les les dégâts soit couvert c'est
simplement pas leê même mécanisme on se
souvient tous de la sécheresse il y a
quelques mois et quelques semaines
seulement on parlait de la sécheresse
quand on voit toute cette eau qui tombe
qu'est-ce que quels enseignements vous
en tirez en terme de gestion de l'eau
bah les enseignements que j'en tire
c'est d'abord qu'on est un pays qui
était plutôt un pays à climat tempéré
plutôt et que nous découvrons depuis une
quinzaine d'années parce que c'est pas
c'est pas simplement depuis 15 jours
vous avez raison mais
le fait que nous avons une arythmie
climatique avec d'abord une arythmie en
soi et par ailleurs des phénomènes
exceptionnels ça me fait penser que
l'eau va être rare et ou trop abondante
et que donc on a besoin de penser le
cycle dans sa durée courte et longue
d'ailleurs et de regarder quand il y a
beaucoup d'eau toute l'eau qu'on a dans
le Pas de calé c'est de l'eau entreau
manifestement c'est de l'eau reau
puisque les sols ne peuvent pas
l'absorber il faudrait pouvoir la la
mettre dans des réserves il y a quelque
chose à penser de réservve de
substitution qui permettrai de les
remplir quand il y a trop d'eau de
limiter alors on névitera jamais et tout
mais de limiter les effets des
inondations et de pouvoir parce que je
le rappelle cette zone du pas decalis
cet été elle était en alerte chess par y
avait trop peu d'eau qui était tombé
c'était une des zones où il était tombé
le moins d'eau cet été alors qu'on av
plutôt une année un été plus plus vieux
en tout cas sur la partie nord du pays
et donc si on pouvait réfléchir
simplement les choses en disant il y a
quelque chose d'assez bon de bon sens au
fond de se dire il y a trop d'eau donc
des mégabassines par exemple comme dans
les deux serves alors qu'on sait que le
le comment dire le débat est très vif le
débat est très vif et c'est dommage
parce que je pense que les mégaabassines
c'est exactement ça c'est une
d'afleurement qui se remplit très vite
et donc qui déborde très vite d'ailleurs
dans les dans les deux cèvres en Vendé
on a beaucoup d'eau on est en limite
d'ailleurs il faudrait pas qu'on ait
beaucoup de plus viométrie
supplémentaire pour avoir des
difficultés ça permet de remplir ses
ouvrages mégabassin si on veut les
appeler ainsi ou réserve de substitution
moi je pense que c'est la logique est
une réserve de substitution on prend
l'hiver ce qu'on évite de pomper l'été
c'est comme ça qu'il faut raisonner et
je pense qu'on a besoin de penser notre
cycle l'au en dérèglement climatique nos
outils aujourd'hui ils sont peu pensés
en dérèglement climatiques et c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on travaille face au début
de polémique le gouvernement a décidé
hier soir de de prolonger d'un an la
dérogation qui permet au salariés
bénéficiaires de de titre restaurant de
faire leur courses avec décision prise
un mois et demi avant la fin pourquoi ça
n'a pas été anticipé vu l'inflation
alimentaire qui est toujours présente
d'abord c'est une disposition
législative donc ça se ça se fait pas
comme ça si je peux dire deuxème élément
deuxième élément c'est une disposition
qui avait été soutenue par le
gouvernement qui était d'origine
sénatoriale si j'ai bonne mémoire qui
visait à pouvoir l'utiliser le le ticket
restaurant pour d'autres usjat que ceux
pour lequels ils sont prévus ça
s'appelle ticket restaurant
et pas ticket alimentaire si je peux
dire simplement le bon sens que nous
avons aussi au gouvernement à imposer
que même si on est dans une phase de de
stabilisation d'une inflation déjà
élevée il y avait utilité pour un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes nos
concitoyens à pouvoir utiliser ces
tickets restaurants pour l'alimentation
courante si je peux dire et donc dans
les dans les dans les usages qui sont
ceux aujourd'hui prévus par la loi vous
parlez du bon sens pour les resturateurs
c'est pas du bon sens he ils sont pas
contents oui oui ils trouvent que oui
alors quand il y a une mesure il y a
toujours des gens qui qui considèent que
mais à la vérité il y a quand même des
gens il y a un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens on a des réunions ce matin
au ministère de l'agriculture c'est les
questions de l'aide alimentaire on a un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens qui
sont en difficulté pour l'alimentation
bon donc faut aussi se confronter à la
réalité même si je comprends la
situation des restaurateurs
reconnaissons aussi que sous la crise
covid nous avons beaucoup aidé les
restaurateurs donc chacun doit
comprendre aussi qu'on doit chacun faire
sa part et donc il me semble que c'est
une mesure de bon sens que de faire en
sorte que nos concitoyens puissent
utiliser encore on a l'impression que
c'est de l'improvisation je je je le
redis hein c'estes décision prises un
mois et demi avant avant la fin de cette
dérogation symboliquement est-ce que
vous craignez en fait de refaire une
erreur équivalente au à la baisse de 5 €
des aPL que ça reste dans les esprits ça
non non mais là c'était c'est c'est plus
compliqué que ça pardon de le dire de se
dire parce qu'il y a des effets les
restaurateurs peuvent légitimement dire
ça n'est pas l'objet d'abord je rappelle
que le ticket restaurant c'est un c'est
un sujet paritaire parce que c'est entre
les les employeurs et les salariés c'est
comme ça que c'est construit on pourrait
d'ailleurs se poser la question de pour
pourquoi à chaque fois on vient voir le
gouvernement pour dire faut arbitrer
faut faire ceci parce que c'est alimenté
par les par vous et moi quand vous en
bénéficiez et et par les les patrons par
les par les entreprises bon bref qu'on
puisse se poser la question avant de
prendre une décision active et qu'on
puisse réfléchir et et un mois et demi
avant le terme les tickets restaurant
fonctionnent il fonctionneront à partir
du 1er janvier il y a toute l'attitude
pour le faire dans une disposition
législative l'inflation alimentaire vous
en parliez et vous parliez aussi tout à
l'heure des cultures de betterave qui
étaient dévasté dans la première région
productrice en France sachant que le
sucre et l'une des denrées alimentaires
qui augmentent le plus ça va avoir des
conséquences ces inondations sur les
prix du sucre 2000 hectares PE peut-être
pas quand même mais il me semble que il
faut toujours être vigilant et c'est
vrai que c'est une des difficultés dans
le dérèglement climatique là on a une
inflation qui est liée à d'autres sujets
énergie emballage et autres mais dans le
dérèglement climatique on peut avoir des
effets qui soient liés à ça et qui
produisent de l'inflation je vous donne
un deuxième exemple c'est l'exemple de
l'huile d'olive la récolte en Espagne
d'huile d'olive a diminué de quasiment
50 %. c'est le premier producteur de
tête d'huile d'olive du monde bon bah ça
ça va se voir sur les prix on a des prix
qui ont été multipliés par deux ou trois
c'est une inflation d'une autre nature
que celle qu'on on a connu à partir de
2022 donc oui il faut qu'on ait une
vigilance c'est pour ça que la question
de la souveraineté alimentaire est une
question importante il faut qu'on ait
une vigilance parce qu'il faut qu'on on
assure nos besoins y compris dans du
dérèglement climatique parce que sinon
on aura des difficultés c'est important
ce que vous dites parce qu'on est en
pleine négociation commerciale entre
distributeurs et industriel et donc
producteur aussi les aléas climatiques
vont avoir une incidence dans la
négation on parle de deux sujets qui
sont visibles qui sont le sucre alors
c'est des sujets mondiaux le sucre en
plus c'est mais là les producteurs vont
y perdre non non les producteurs non
puisque la question c'est de la
rémunération et que la loi égalim m'a
permis de garantir ça après on est
plutôt sur une baisse sur un certain
nombre de produits je pense au au céréal
en particulier où le prix ont plutôt
baissé structurellement mais je signale
juste que dans certains cas il peut
s'avérer que compenu du dérèglement
climatique ça'ppuiss sur certains
produits faire des effets que je viens
d'évoquer par exemple sur l'huile
d'olive et les agriculteurs les
producteurs ils doivent se préparer et y
perdre dans cette négociation qui est en
cours bah ça n'est pas la volonté du
gouvernement je rappelle que depuis
201728 avec mes prédécesseurs c'était
Stéphan traver h on fait de mieux
rémunérer la matière première agricole
et de faire en sorte que à chaque fois
ça soit pas le sacrifice soit demandé
aux agriculteurs donc il peut pas y
avoir une négociation qui fasse en sorte
qu'on perde notre souveraineté
alimentaire par la perte de nos
agriculteurs parce qu'à la fin on
dépendra des autres alors pour le coup
l'inflation elle sera encore plus forte
parce qu'elle sera dans la main de gens
qui sont nos amis ou parfois pas nos
amis d'ailleurs on va dire les choses
comme elles sont donc la souveraineté
alimentaire et donc la rémunération des
agriculteurs c'est un élément de long
terme de lutte contre l'inflation
j'invite et j'invite pardon la grande
distribution à penser le long terme et
terme et à penser souveraineté et pas
intérêt du moment privé vous parliez à
l'instant des céréales vous étiez la
semaine dernière en Ukraine à ce propos
l'entrée de l'Ukraine dans l'Union
européenne serait une catastrophe hein
ce sont les les mots de de d'Arnaud
Rousseau le patron de la FNSEA pour lui
l'agriculture ukrainienne ne joue pas
avec les mêmes règles que nous donc ça
va forcément forcément impacter nos
agriculteurs est-ce qu'il a raison à
date il y a une grande différence entre
l'agriculture ukrainienne et et
l'agriculture européenne 2uxième élément
il y a un élément de solidarité
vis-à-vis d'un pays qui est en guerre
enfin il faut aller voir sur place pour
constater d'ailleurs il y a des
entreprises y compris deagroalimentaire
ou agricole qui son euré oui non
attention au message qu'on envoie
deuxième élément vous savez très bien
que les entrées dans l'Union européenne
c'est un processus de négociation un
processus de convergence y compris des
réglementations enfin on en est pas là
si je peux dire mais l'Union européenne
a ouvert la la la boîte si je peux dire
de la négociation de la capacité
d'adhésion de demande d'adhésion
travaillons là-dessus me semble-t-il et
c'est vrai qu'il y a des distorsions de
concurrence on parle du plus grand des
plus grand sans doute même l' le plus
grand producteur agricole en Europe
c'est ce que je c'est ce que je voulais
vous dire en revanche c'est le plus
grand producteur c'est 25 % de la
production agricole européenne
l'équivalent c'est 15 % du marché
mondial des céréales c'est un
déséquilibre absolument énorme et donc
il faut se poser la question de
l'Ukraine dans l'Europe si l'Ukraine
dans l'Europe mais on en est pas là je
le répète il y a des nécessités de
convergence mais ça peut pas être une
concurrence avec les pays européens ça
peut êtreun puissance agricole
européenne qu'il faut construire avec eu
parce que si c'est pour venir sur le
marché européen à ce moment-là on aurait
tout perdu d'abord l'Ukraine pas
grand-chose et nous beaucoup parce que
nos agriculteurs seraient exposés à une
concurrence qui serait de voyale donc on
a besoin de penser l'adhésion ou la ou
la coopération avec l'Ukraine dans une
perspective de puissance européenne
mondiale sur la scène de la souveraineté
de la sécurité alimentaire l'Europe on
va en parler parce que elle va proposer
demain la prolongation ENF la Commission
européenne propose la la prolongation
pour 10 ans du glyphosate sur le sol
européen et c'est demain qui a lieu un
nouveau vote important celui des 27
membres sur cette proposition le mois
dernier la France s'était abstenue que
va voter la France deain
à propos du glyphosate on attend les
derniers éléments de proposition de
l'Union européenne s'il y a pas de
changement il y a pas de raison que le
vote change enfin il y a une forme de
donc toujours une abstention s'il y a
pas de changement il y a pas de raison
que le vote change pour ça veut dire ça
veut dire que le glyphosate sera
prolongé mais on l'a dit depuis le début
1 l'interdiction totale ça n'est pas
possible alors pardon je sais que c'est
pas forcément populaire de le dire ainsi
mais l' pris 201 on a regardé aussi s'il
y avait des alternative on a constaté
d'ailleurs qu'il y avait pas
d'alternative je pense par exle ce qu'on
appelle l'agriculture de conservation
l'agriculture de conservation c'est une
agriculture sans travail du sol cette
agriculture est très performante d'un
point de vue du stockage carbone très
performante et de la qualité des sols on
n pas d'alternative aujourd'hui donc 6
ans après Marc F n toujours pas
d'alternative si vous trouvez une
alternative à labourer par autre chose
qu'un produit de cette nature pardon
pardon mais moi je suis pas
agricultriste je vous POS la question
parand vous avez raison mais demandz
cher il y a des maladi sur lequel on a
toujours pas de médicament ok donc c'est
pareil donc il y a des maladies humaines
sur lequell ça fait 30 ans qu'on cherche
on a des difficultés parfois 40 ans
parfois 70 ans et il y a parfois des
impasses techniques qui existent en
agriculture sur lequel on n pas
d'alternative a des pays européens qui
s'en passent P auun
payemb d'accord le Luxembourg ne se pas
il y a aucun pays européen qui se passe
du glyphosate et par contre il y a un
seul pays européen qui a réduit
l'utilisation de glyphosate c'est la
France c'est ça la réalité donc on peut
toujours déclamer si je peux dire des
choses mais le Luxembourg a une position
du moment mais le ambourg aujourd'hui
tous les usages glyphosate ou les usages
du glyphosate sont plus importants qu'en
France donc la position de la France
elle est simple c'est là où il y a des
alternatives il faut qu'on continue à
les pousser pourquoi avoir une
trajectoire de réduction et là où il y a
pas des alternatives on cherche pour
essayer de trouver avec la volonté de
trouver mais là où il y a pas
d'alternative il faut continuer à
pouvoir l'utiliser parce que sinon on va
mettre en impasse complète les
agricultures français diminuer
l'utilisation du du glyphosat est
suffisant non clairement si on lit le
spécialiste mondial de la maladie de
Parkinson bass Bloom qui s'est adressé à
vous dans le journal Le Monde je le cite
il existe aujourd'hui un faisceau de
preuve scientifique indiquant que le
glyphosate est une cause possible de
Parkinson une étude récente a montré que
l'exposition au glyphosate était
associée à des signes de lésions
cérébrales des maladies de Parkinson et
d'Alzheimer ces effets ont été observés
dans la population générale il vous
demande et c'est pas le seul
scientifique de V de à le demander de
voter contre euh l'utilisation de
l'herbicide j'essaie d'être cohérent
avec moi-même déjà c'est c'est c'est
c'est une une chose importante
euh les décisions qui sont celles de
l'Europe elles sont appuyées sur un
organisme s'appelle l'fsa qui parfois
produisent des décisions d'interdiction
laquelle FFSA d'ailleurs produit des
analyses qui sont le produit de ce que
dit laness alors c'est pas à la carte en
fait soit ce que dit laness ce que dit
l'fsa on considère que ça a du crédit
scientifique et quand ils disent quelque
chose quand ils disent quelque chose
avec parfois des doutes c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'on dit pas réutilisation
générale avec parfois des interrogations
des études complémentaires qu'on demande
on les suit mais on peut pas dire c'est
à la carte en fonction de ce qu'on pense
soi-même l'fsa dans une dans une étude
combinée européenne avec plusieurs
autorités don laness dit que à date le
sujet n'est pas celui que vous évoquez
par d'Ares scientifiques il faut suivre
il faut suivre aussi les autorités parce
que sinon chut cohérent avec nous-même
monsieur le ministre je vous assure que
moi je m'intéresse aussi à la santé des
Français parce et notamment des
agriculteurs qui sontè les agriculteurs
j'ai j'ai j'ai une famille j'ai des
enfants donc voyez pardon je
j'accepterai jamais qu'on fasse la leçon
sur le fait que moi aussi je défends les
intérêts de la santé des Français FR et
je m'en préoccupe ce qui fait d'ailleurs
que parfois on a des décisions qui sont
compliquées sur un certain nombre de
moléculle mais que je tiens parce que je
considère qu'il faut les tenir sur le
cas particulier d'abord il y a pas de
décision de justice c'est le fond
d'indemnisation donc
Lena oui le fond d'indemnisation
première intention l'a fait deuxième
élément je rajoute que c'est un usage
qui est interdit désormais en France que
c'est un usage
domestique qui a qui a ou les
agriculteurs
il les conditionition d'utilisation les
conditions d'usage on sait très bien
d'ailleurs que Monsanto à l'époque s'est
fait condamné pour les conditions
d'usage la façon sont en alerté ou pas
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire quelles sont
les précautions qu'il faut prendre comme
quand vous prenez un médicament vous
avez sur la boîte les conditions d'usage
et ce qu'il faut faire est-ce qu'il faut
pas faire et donc c'est comme ça qu'il
faut le regarder donc ne tirons pas d'un
cas particulier qui est un cas d'usun
d'une sur une molécule mais qui était en
combinaison avec d'autres le produit
lui-même a été interdit en 2006 c'est
pas moi c'est y a 17 ans qu'il a été
interdit et donc on regarde à chaque
fois s'il y a des il y a des
controverses on regarde à chaque fois
s'il y a des des effets mais globalement
ce que dit l'fsa ce que dit l'anè c'est
de confirmer la position qui a été la
sienne de depuis toujours sur la
question du glyphosat et donc essayons
si on commence à remettre en cause ça
veut dire que ceux qui diront au fond
faut pas interdire parce que moi je
pense queil y a pas de danger que l'fsa
et l'an disent il y a danger il faut
interdire on remettra en cause de la
même façon donc il faut qu'on essaie de
tenir une position qui est une position
d'écouter les scientifiqu alors il y a
toujours des des scientifiques qui
disent ceci je suis pas d'accord ça
c'est la controver scientifque pardon
l'fsa et l'an c'est des dizaines de
scientifiques c'est des centaines de
scientifiques alors si on les écoute pas
et que chacun peut dire ce qu'il pense
je comprends qu'on puisse avoir des
convictions mais il faut ça soit appuisé
appuyé sur la science pardon mais c'est
ce que disaient les scientifiques il le
disaient déjà en 2017 quand Emmanuel
Macron a dit qu'il allait interdire le
glyphosate en 3 ans oui mais on a
travaillé avec les les les équipes de de
chercheurs des instituts techniques on a
regardé partout o on pouvait réduire ce
qu'on pouvait faire et partout mais
c'était à l'époque d'une une volonté qui
avait été exprimée et on est au
rendez-vous je répète sur le glyphosate
nous sommes le seul pays du monde à
avoir baissé de 30 % les usages donc on
a bien compris abstention de main de la
France une modification proposition
communautaire on est encore dans comme
vous savez c'est toujours au derniers
moments que les choses se nouent parfois
Marc Phen dans le Sud-Ouest ils
appellent ça une une tempête sanitaire
les beauvins sont touché par une maladie
qui les affaiblit elle provoque fièvre
amaigrissement lésion bucal le plus
souvent les vaches survivent mais les
échanges commerciaux donc avec les avec
l'étranger notamment sont évidemment
perturbés comment éviter que ça ça
continue alors euh c'est produit aussi
du dérèglement climatique tout ça me me
fait dire ici à votre micro ce matin que
il va falloir qu'on continue à œuvrer
pour anticiper pour rendre les systèmes
plus résilients à des maladies à des des
à des phénomène climatique parce que on
va avoir des difficultés majeures le
statut quo c'est la mort de
l'agriculture si on fait le statut quo
des pratiques il faut qu'on qu'on
prépare nos agriculteurs et qu'on les
accompagne dans les grandes transitions
qui sur les réserves d'eau pour assurer
un minimum et qui sur les sujets
sanitaires alors je réponds à votre
question sanitaire c'est une maladie qui
vient du sud
hein Nord-Afrique et qui vient de de
l'Espagne puisquil était elle était un
peu présente en Espagne c'est transmis
par les moustiques donc il a une maladie
transmise par les moustiques il y a pas
grand chose à faire en dehors de
d'essayer de regarder ce qu'on peut
faire d'un point de vue économique
premier élément on a libéré tout de
suite les les frontières avec l'Espagne
et l'Italie qui est 95 % du marché de
jeun bovvin il part dans ces deux pays
ça a permis que d'éviter que les prix
s'effondre et je tiens à saluer c'est
aussi la coopération européenne ça c'est
les les bonnes relations qu'on
entretient avec l'Italie et l'Espagne
qui ont permis que en moins de 10 jours
ce qui est un record on ne freine pas
les les exportations ça peut avoir un
effet sur les prix mais c'est plutôt
marginal l'effet principal pour les prod
conducteur c'est des animaux qui sont
malades j'étais l'autre jour dans les
Pyrénées Atlantiques avec une vache qui
avit perdu 200 kg en un mois et et qui
qui avait du mal à se tenir encore sur
sur ses pattes si vous me permettez
cette expression là c'est une perte qui
peut à terme être très lourde pour
l'éleveur et donc on va prendre en
charge aujourd'hui on est en train de
documenter les choses pour prendre en
charge les beauins qui vont mourir il y
a quand même un taux de mortalité et
deux les les surcoups vétérinaires pour
faire en sorte que ce surcou là soit pas
principalement à la charge de l'éleveur
après on risque d'avoir une acalmie
avant une résurgence au printemps et
c'est ça auquel il faut se préparer et
il faut globalement se préparer un
système sanitaire qui va être très
sollicité on a on est le cette maladie
est apparu au moment où commencer la
vaccination sur la gripe avire c'est
vous dire à quel point les services du
ministère qu'il faut saluer les équipes
terrain les vétérinaires sont hyper
mobilisés euh sur des sujets qui sont
quand même des sujets parfois très
dramatiques pour les éleveurs